[Music]
in a polarized world the next
installment of the franchise all about
balance and non-attachment will be
worshipped hated and obsessed over until
it's not even fun to talk about anymore
this is not going to go the way you
think yeah we know Star Wars fans by now
Star Wars the last Jedi forget the love
letter to the originals that was the
force awakens
because episode 8 subverts everything
you've come to expect making it the
worst one ever
oh who invited the original honest
trailer voice back are you really gonna
do the old ones or better / new ones are
better thing we did with the force
awakens the only way to talk about Star
Wars now is in absolutes
so yes kind of city of you but fine
making last Jedi a refreshing update to
a predictable formula that spits in the
face of everything you once lost whiner
traitor me the new class of heroes
coming into their own
like Rey who after being called by
Luke's lightsaber is called by the Jedi
texts called by a big wet hole and
called by her greatest frenemy
yet still gets zero answers to any of
her questions food hide finances him I
was right PO who grows from a hotshot
sexy pilot to a treasonous failure with
more blood on his hands than the empire
first order same difference and Finn who
went from a deserter running away from
the war to a deserter running away from
the war with the help of newcomer rose
he'll learn to put the greater good
above himself thanks to a pointless side
quest to Casino Royale because how dare
they spend 15 minutes connecting the
action to a larger thing the larger
theme being is it possible to miss pod
racing I didn't think so
but here we are but forget about the
butthurt fanboys who were just mad the
movie isn't closer to the one they wrote
in their heads
hey because they're still all the old
favorites like Leia a battle-hardened
general trying to keep the spark of hope
and she's in a coma
Chewbacca who gets nothing to do and
Luke Skywalker who after sad old Han and
sad old Leia really drives home how your
heroes are all sad and old now he's
turned his back on the franchise after
watching the prequels legacy of the Jedi
his failure and not even reruns of a new
hope can change his mind that she moved
because what Star Wars fans really
needed was to see their Idol throw his
lightsaber away like it was some kind of
joke and Star Wars is not a joke to me
you have anything to talk to you about
Rian Johnson ruined my childhood like he
ruined the laws of space battle there
are no laws to space battle there should
be Luke isn't the only Skywalker who has
issues with the franchise kylo Ren is
back and he's demanding a full reboot
but the past time kill it if you have to
when he doesn't look like he's about to
cry which is always
[Music]
watch as he teaches The Fader fanboy act
the muddy duck mask and his shirt you
distracted me on purpose too late moving
on get ready for truly unexpected
answers to the puzzles of Episode seven
that can only be answered by asking what
are the most disappointing answers to
the puzzles of episode seven like who
are Ray's parents nobody who is Snoke
some dead guy
and how did Maz Kanata get Luke's
lightsaber it doesn't matter and you're
stupid for asking that after all the
hours of speculation and analysis was
genuinely a celebrating whoa how do we
keep from a certain point of viewing
each other yeah we're both pretty big
Star Wars nerds huh so gear up for the
most divisive Star Wars film ever made
where Ryan Johnson either doesn't
understand the lore or he made the first
Star Wars movie that lives up to the
values it preaches instead of endorsing
Royal bloodlines and reckless aggression
okay enough division let's say our
favorite things about it on the count of
three one two three between guard
oh but Yoda eating look with a stick
wargs wait really yeah I'll own it
okay now least favorites although not
telling you wonder when I get now keepo
down a peg but come on they're taking
shuttles to a fort why make everyone
think they're gonna die again argue that
though I'm sure people will should we do
this again for solo yeah I'm not gonna
see that crap story after Star Wars fan
base salt Blu ray Luke teat milker
Carrie Poppins Finn the human
I've been kissed by a rose on the brain
Kai's so serious
Snoke give me the car key keys your car
key nerf herder shortround pew Breana
doors bucks to be you
and redemption for star wars kid star
wars the last one you'll pay to see
until the next one comes out maybe it is
time for my fandom to end
did you hear JJ finished the script
prepa sewed nine my fandom is back
temporarily want more Star Wars stuff
click the box on the left as we dive
deeper into our serious questions for
the last Jedi or click the Box on the
right to watch us make F into an A play
with puppies what the cuss broccoli my
mortal enemy the inner machinations of
my mind are an enigma the first Jedi
Temple was in stable Hirsch Nebraska